I grew up on a beef farm in Missouri and
like everybody else had raised his
livestock we raised a lot of our own
feed to stay in business and we raised
corn and soybeans and hay and we grind
this stuff up into a flour and we'd add
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
make pellets you feed those calves for
about six nine months and then you ship
them off to be butchered or maybe two
other theaters and you always save back
the very best ones for yourself and you
knock them in the head kneed him it's a
real simple cycle on the farm and the
thing that fascinated me as a teenager
was that we went to a great deal of
trouble for those calves and yet as a
family we ate out of the very same field
we keep back five rows of corn for
ourself we had a garden at the end of
the field where we grew our peas and
beans and squash and tomatoes and we
wanted to live to be a hundred with no
aches and pains and we didn't give
ourselves the very same vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals that we gave
the calves and I always used to ask my
daddy say hey pops how come we go to all
that trouble for those calves and not
for ourselves and he'd say shut up boy
getting farm-fresh food fresh air lots
of free exercise don't ask complicated
questions and I was glad to get rid of
the farm exercise and go to AG school at
the University of Missouri and there my
major was an animal husbandry and
nutrition my minor was in field crops
and soils and I began to learn technical
things about soil chemistry and how it
related to tons and bushels per acre and
Ag economics but I didn't get an answer
to my basic question until I became a
freshman veterinary student at the
University of Missouri and there I
learned that the reason why we put all
these vitamins and minerals and trace
minerals into animal feeds bottom line
is because we don't have insurance for
them
we don't have BlueCross BlueShield major
medical hospitalization Medicare
Medicaid and if we were to use a human
healthcare type of system for animals
it'd be sticker shock for you your
hamburger would cost you two hundred and
seventy five dollars a pound boneless
skinless chicken breast be four hundred
fifty bucks a pound
dozen eggs be fifty dollars just to pay
for the healthcare so we learned that we
could keep the price of animal products
such as meat and dairy and poultry and
eggs down to where the average American
could afford them simply by
significantly reducing or totally
eliminating healthcare cost and we do
that in animals by preventing and curing
diseases with nutrition well after
graduating vet school I went to Africa
for a couple of years and got to work
with Marlin Perkins from the old Mutual
of Omaha Wild Kingdom days and I was
kind of a kid
at the play Frank buck use a
tranquilizer gun Tromp all over central
in South Africa for a couple years and
then Marlon sent me a telegram and
invited me back to the States he'd
gotten a seven and a half million dollar
grant from the National Institutes of
Health and this was more than 30 years
ago and this was the study pollution and
ecology in the environment and my job as
the wildlife veterinarian on the project
was to do autopsies of animals who died
of natural causes in the big zoos around
the United States and I was supposed to
identify or find a species of animals
was ultra sensitive to pollution and
we're going to use that animal much like
the old coal miners used to use Canaries
you know how that goes i take the canary
down in the mine and if methane gas or
carbon monoxide were to leak in the mine
the Canaries were more sensitive than
the men and would drop off the persian
die and long before the men were in
danger of suffocating or blowing up well
make a long story short after some 12
plus years of working on this project
and done some 17,500 autopsies and over
four hundred and fifty four species of
animals plus three thousand human beings
for a comparison and what I learned was
that every animal and human being who
dies of natural causes dies of a
nutritional deficiency disease and I got
kind of excited about nutrition again
and I wrote 75 scientific papers on the
subject wrote chapters four eight
multi-author textbooks actually
contributed a textbook myself a thousand
pages two thousand illustrations and
through the news releases that run the
big universities I worked with I was on
20/20 within 1,700 newspapers around the
world for the UPI and AP news wire
services and with all this public
exposure and with all the scientific
exposure I couldn't get people who are
in a position of authority either in
medical research or in politics to get
to concerned or interested in preventing
and curing diseases and human beings
with nutrition just like we did in
animals well I got frustrated enough I
went back to school in Portland Oregon
became a physician and I practiced there
for 12 years as a general family
practitioner and I sewed up chainsaw
wounds delivered babies used everything
that I'd learned in veterinary nutrition
of my human patients and was no surprise
to me that it worked just as well in
people as it did in animals well to get
started I always like to talk about
longevity and he
being has the genetic potential to live
healthily to be a hundred and twenty I'm
going to prove that to you in just a
minute
unfortunately Americans do a lousy job
when it comes to longevity our average
lifespan in the United States is seventy
five point five about half were
genetically capable of in 1990 when the
World Health Organization examined the
top thirty two industrialized nations on
earth the United States came out 17th
there's actually 16 other countries
whose peoples live longer than we do we
ranked 19th and healthfulness that meant
that there were 18 other countries whose
peoples live longer than we do before
they develop heart disease and cancer
and diabetes and arthritis and
osteoporosis we ranked 23rd when it came
to live birth and first years survived
abilities of babies and we ranked dead
last 32 out of 32 when it came to
preventing birth defects now what all
this means is we have the highest price
health care system in the world but not
the best it also means that we have the
most envied health care system in the
world but not the best we have the most
technologically advanced health care
system in the world but not the best
well I had a good friend by the name of
Christopher Byrd for many many years
over 20 years in Chris I was a
best-selling author on books on
organically grown food he was an expert
in the subject and I was always trying
to give him vitamins and minerals and he
refused to take him and he'd tell me doc
I bring my own cooler I don't eat any
hotel food I bring my own organically
grown food and so I don't need to take
vitamins and minerals well I was
changing planes again in Atlanta had an
hour to kill picked up the local
newspaper and guess whose obituaries
found in the newspaper Chris Byrd first
again he was a best-selling author of
books the secret life of plants the
secrets of the soil and he died at age
68 from a ruptured aneurysm a type of
stroke seven and a half years before the
average American dies and he led a
pristine life lived up in the mountains
at an organically grown garden collected
herbs you know like Euell Gibbons and
ate wild hickory nuts and all those kind
of things and the cause of his belief he
died of a copper deficiency and I'll
show you in a minute the copper
deficiency causes ruptured aneurysms and
it's just a tragic thing that the people
have so much to give and died at less
than half their genetic potential for
longevity a lot of people say to me doc
I don't need to take vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals because I
use herbs now herbs are not nutrition
you have to under
that herbs are not nutrition they are
great plant medicines they're safer
they're more economical in most cases
are more effective than prescription
medications that doctors will give you
but their plant medicines if you have
diarrhea they can tighten you up if you
have constipation they loosen you up if
you have a hypertension or high blood
pressure and bring it down if you have a
fever and bring it down but don't expect
to get enough calcium or selenium or
boron or copper or vitamin A from herbs
well I've been doing biomedical research
and clinical research and animals and
human beings and I can tell you no
matter how you look at health and
longevity whether it be in animals or
human beings there's only really two
concepts you have to deal with concept
number one I refer to is avoid stepping
on the landmines this is where you don't
want to throw away your healthy physical
body wastefully you don't want to smoke
don't abuse alcohol don't do drugs don't
jog down the highway at two o'clock in
the morning wearing an all-black ninja
suit you're gonna get hit by a truck
mirror right whenever a doctor says
here's our options never say doc
whatever you say you're the you're the
doctor when a doctor says here's our
options what you want to do is take a
look I want copies of all these records
and tests and when copies of the x-rays
and go visit three other doctors and
three other hospitals you want to talk
to 12 of their living patients that had
gone through this procedure talk to him
see if you really want to do this I mean
you do this for your driveway and your
roof and your fence in your yard and all
that kind of stuff why not for your own
physical body
that's concept number one now that
you've avoided the landmines you're in a
good position to do all the positive
things that you need to do to go on to
live you over 100 basically what you
want to do is take along essential
nutrients 60 that's 600 minerals 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids and
three essential fatty acids they're
called essential nutrients for two
reasons number one your body cannot
manufacture them you must consume these
every day either as food or supplements
number two if any one of these essential
nutrients is missing for a couple of
months couple of years you get on the
average ten deficiency diseases you have
everything to gain doesn't lose by
supplementing properly well the medical
profession of course has this malignant
dumb belief that you can get everything
you need from your four food groups
my favorite article of all time in the
press was April 6 1992 Time magazine
cover article the real power of vitamins
new research shows it may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
aging six positive pages if you haven't
read it I'd urge you to go to a public
library school library dig it out and
read it there's only one negative
sentence and as you might guess it was
offered by a medical doctor who was
actually contacted by the writer
article said what do you think about
vitamins and minerals and and trace
minerals as supplements for human
nutrition here's what he said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do any good
sniffs dr. Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote
now Missouri translation of that is
you're just peeing away your money
you might as a lot of your dollars throw
in a toilet and flush them away you can
get everything you need from your four
food groups is what he's trying to say
well I'd rather pee out 50 cents for
dollar day worth of excess vitamins and
minerals that's cheap insurance think
about how much money it's been for
coffee or soft drinks or newspapers and
that kind of stuff every day 50 cents to
a dollar day to maintain and repair your
body and it's kind of fascinating that
most people don't do it just remember
will you pay that doctor out of your own
pocket or indirectly through insurance
or indirectly through taxes and Medicare
Medicaid not a single penny of that goes
to better understand managed treat
prevent or cure catastrophic diseases
and kids breast cancer and women
prostate cancer and men now a lot of
people ask me why did you call your
original tape dead doctors don't lie
that's because I believed for a long
time because I had done medical research
for over 20 years in large medical
research institutes medical schools the
various laboratories and I always had a
belief in the medical system but I was
very disappointed when I learned that
doctors don't know the most about health
and longevity doctors don't know the
most about disease they do know about
procedures you know how to fix your
bones when you break them and that sort
of thing how to do a cat scan and so I
began to look in the medical journals
and sure enough the first article ever
published on health and longevity of
American doctors was published in JAMA
in June 15th 1895 a little over a
hundred years ago they said at that time
doctors lived to be fifty four point six
I redid the study 97 years later using
the same obituary techniques that they
did in JAMA
this was January 20th 1993 in a
particular issue of JAMA and it turned
out the doctors lived to be 57.69
rounded up to 58 to give them the
benefit of the doubt and doctors just
went berserk when I said dad I mean this
was the most outrageous thing they'd
ever heard my principle is my premise is
that doctors don't live as long as the
average couch potato in America and I
purposely put that figure out there 58
to try and challenge people well doctors
me
looked at all the insurance actuarial
charge they got 250,000 dead doctors he
said your groups too small so they
looked at 250,000 dead doctors they say
doctors don't live to be 58 they died 62
they still don't live to be seventy five
point five like the average couch potato
we actually reran this again using the
entire obituary history for 1996 and
then for the entire 1996 of all the
doctors dying in 1996 with all the
medical treatments and drugs and
procedures and everything in transplants
doctors and in that study lived to be 70
still five and a half years short of the
average couch potato in America so they
still have never proven that doctors
live as long as everybody else that's
why dead doctors don't lie now if you do
everything right how old can you live to
be is it worth all the effort I believe
it is here's one Christian Mortensen
from San Rafael California in August of
1995 turned 113 August 4 1996 he turned
114 he's still going strong certainly
can live to be a hundred and fifteen
smokes a couple of cigars a day like
George Burns will also live to be over
100 it certainly wasn't a guess the only
exercise George Burns ever did was put
the cigars in his mouth this gal here
Dorothy be from South Africa in July of
1995 turned 114 and when she was asked
by the media Dora
what do you attribute your health and
longevity to she did not say that we owe
it all to our annual physical or our HMO
she said I ate locust every day you know
a little grasshopper she's not a
vegetarian she's little animals pumpkin
seeds tortoise meat wild herbs dried
fruit and starts each day with a cup of
coffee this gal here Margaret Skeets
from Radford Virginia in 1994 was the
oldest documented living American when
she died at age 115 fell over and
fractured her hip three weeks later she
was dead from complications of
osteoporosis a simple calcium deficiency
and we'll talk more about this in a
minute unfortunately this is not unusual
75 percent of all Americans over the age
of 65 who fracture a hip or major leg
bone don't live 90 days they die of
pneumonia pulmonary embolism stroke and
other complications that fracture Susie
Brunson praying to her family in
December of 1994 was the oldest American
when she died at age 123 and they based
her claim on her birth date December
25th 1870 which was recorded in the
family Bible in this fellow here
Francisco Baron wave at chop arena
Cobre 1995
from a little town outside of Bogota
Colombia turn 125 when he was asked by
the media of Francisco what do you
attribute your health and longevity to
he said well I drink a gallon of goat's
milk every day also is kind of
fascinating in his birthday announcement
this is not a is a birthday
announcement said that over 40 years ago
his physicians told him he only had a
couple of months to live so he had his
sons building a coffin and he's been
waking up every morning for more than 40
years sitting by that coffin waiting to
die good night time comes he goes to bed
wakes up the next morning sits by the
coffin waits to die
now he's still going strong and all the
doctors who told him that more than 40
years ago or long since dead this fellow
here Hamoudi al Abdullah from Syria died
aged 133 and he was still fathering
children after the age of 100 he
remarried for the fourth time when he
was age 80 fathered four boys five girls
nine children after the age of 80 with
the same wife and the me add up the
pregnancies into breastfeeding the time
in between pregnancies he was still
fathering children after the age of 100
this very next one is my very very
favorite this gal mazuma dusty from iran
according to the rocky mountain news
wire services out of Denver and the
Iranian news agency this was January of
1995 she died at age 161 now you have to
give a certain amount of credibility to
this obituaries she died at age 161
because she was survived by six living
children ranging in age from 120 to 128
they hadn't even left home to go to
college in
now her oldest son golem said his mother
had never visited a doctor nor taken any
chemical medications during her life did
take a few herbs so if you kind of think
about it every one of these people who
live to be over a hundred 120 130 160
these people are not from United States
or Canada or Germany or England kind of
interesting isn't it they're most of
them from third world countries they're
farthest away from medical help and they
lived the old so that we're beginning to
collect information here the last one we
want to look at the National Geographic
Society a very respected group of people
scientists and and so forth and support
groups for science comes out with a
monthly magazine the National Geographic
magazine of course and they in January
of 1973 came out with a nifty special
issue on longevity they looked at
cultures whose people have 120 and they
documented the oldest living human being
that they could find based on their
criteria this fella by the name is
Charlie Ms Malone from Azerbaijan a
little country just south of Russian
Georgia in western Russia today they
documented him as being 167 years old
remember this is the National Geographic
Society not the National Enquirer 167
years of age they had a half page
picture of him actually harvesting tea
leaves and a tea plantation still
working eight hours a day six days a
week when he 167 five months later May
of 1973 shirali mismo loft turns 168
goes out and holds the garden for
reporters to show how vigorous he is now
for at least fifteen maybe seventy years
medical doctors in America have been
pooh-poohing the idea that you can live
well beyond a hundred you know people
who lived 115 120 they were one in six
billion it wasn't something that
everybody could look forward to and
anybody who tried to teach people how to
live to be 110 120 hundred 40 were
considered charlatans and quacks and
taking advantage of older people I was
glad to see this come out this is a news
article in the USA Today newspaper in
October of 2000 and it was based on a
article in the journal Science very
respectable Journal and what they said
was forget 100 try living past 120
humans possess a maximum life expectancy
longer than 120 years which had been the
long theorized medical limit in fact
lifespans appear to be increasing over
time with no end in sight
now the cute part of this is
now that there's no doubt about it
everybody agrees that human beings
including Americans have the genetic
capacity to live well beyond 120 doctors
want to take credit for the things that
have actually increased our longevity
from 45 average lifespan in 1895 to 75.5
today which is an increase of about 30
and a half years our sewers and good
clean water Public Health things we
don't have cholera and leptospirosis and
tuberculosis and our food supply nor
water supply anymore we have meat
inspection we have public water works
and things have sewers these are the
things that have extended our lifespan
then there's this salt thing you know
would you believe it or not this medical
dog was really caused a lot of problems
in America how many have ever heard that
using the salt shaker is bad you're
gonna get hypertension right you're
gonna get heart disease and stroke
what's the first thing a good farmer
puts out for his livestock a salt
blocker salt lick in it there's nobody
out in the pasture telling a cow she's
limited to one like a day
I refuse to believe my human patients
are dumber than a cow say look go ahead
and pick up a salt shaker you're gonna
see the lightning won't strike you
you can go ahead and saw your food today
Shing saw your body nothing bad is going
to happen in nineteen eighty percent of
my patients love it they bring me
hundreds of new patients every month one
of you sold and not to feel guilty about
it but 2% the bean counters they see no
Wallach we love you respect you we have
this high priced cardiologist that says
you're flying in the face of all the way
to medical evidence you can't tell
people that they can use a salt shaker
because you're gonna kill him with high
blood pressure and heart disease and
stroke and I've been vindicated in this
belief this was actually a study that
was published in the New York Times
May 22nd 1996 and this study was
abstracted from JAMA the Journal of the
American Medical Association the most
prestigious medical journal in the world
according to themselves now in this
particular journal a dr. Alexander
Gordon Logan who's an epidemiologist and
cardiologist on the teaching staff of
the medical school at the University of
Toronto up in Canada and he took 56
existing studies on hypertension or high
blood pressure and restriction of salt
combined the data from these 56 studies
which included 3,500 and 5 people he
threw away all the conclusions and
re-evaluated the larger group and what
he found out was this if you have normal
blood pressure and your restrict salt it
will not prevent you from getting heart
disease or high blood pressure if you
have hypertension or high blood pressure
and restricts salt 97% of those with
high blood pressure hypertension who
restrict salt will not get any
measurable benefit 97 percent will not
get any measurable benefit 0 2 to 5
percent get measurable benefit but it's
not significant they're only able to
reduce their blood pressure by 3.7
millimeters of mercury so here's what
dr. Alexander Gordon Logan said in JAMA
may 22nd 1996 he said you might as well
go ahead and saw your food to taste it's
a meaningless exercise don't get
paranoid about salt it has nothing to do
with blood pressure problems there has
never been one single iota of proof that
restricting salt has any benefit it's
just one of those medical myths he
called it but I'm gonna call it a
medical Kaka now if it's not salt what
causes high blood pressure well it's not
salt first of all because salt is an
essential nutrient as a combination of
sodium and chloride both of which you
need
according to the American Heart
Association the minimum daily
requirement for 150-pound person for
assault each day is a heaping teaspoon
six to nine grams of salt today now the
Japanese who live longer than we do the
Japanese who live 4.1 years longer than
we do and have half the cancer rate they
eat 12 grams of salt today they three
times assault we do they live four years
longer have half the cardiovascular
disease rate and half the cancer rate we
do and yet they eat three times as much
salt as we do so you're beginning to put
the puzzle together the doctors really
don't know what they're talking about
that's why dead doctors don't lie well
if it's not the salt and if it's not
genetic what is it well it's actually
just a simple mineral deficiency raise
your hand you ever heard that
cholesterol is bad and you got to get it
low in your blood you got to have a low
cholesterol diet otherwise you're gonna
get heart disease right
doctors would like to blame all
cardiovascular disease on cholesterol
we've known for 75 years in animal
industry their cholesterol is not a
boogeyman there's not a single disease
it's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol triglycerides you can find
me one I'll give you a million dollars
in small bills in any offshore account
you want there's not a single diseases
caused by elevated blood cholesterol or
triglycerides elevated blood cholesterol
and triglycerides are really just a
warning signal much like a fever
fevers don't cause infections but when
you have an infection with a bacteria a
virus of fungus may be a parasite you
can get a fever you can have a broken
leg and get if you can have cancer and
get a fever you have liver disease and
get a fever babies get a fever when they
Tease and so you have to kind of sort it
out when somebody comes into a doctor's
office with a fever you have to say well
okay here's my whole list called a
differential diagnosis all the things
cause fever if they're 80 years old you
can quickly rule out teething right but
the rest of you may have did some lab
tests for any rate the same thing is
true for elevated blood cholesterol and
triglycerides when you have elevated
blood pressure on triglycerides it might
mean that you have hypothyroidism or low
functioning thyroid gland you could have
diabetes you could have deficiencies of
niacin and chromium vanadium the
essential fatty acids you can have liver
disease all kinds of reasons why you
might have elevated blood cholesterol
triglycerides
but then themselves don't cause any
problems
now the Eskimos above the Arctic Circle
have a traditional diet as 98% red meat
and blubber they will meet whale blubber
walrus meat while was blubber seal meat
seal blubber bear meat bear fat there's
not a single Eskimo above the Arctic
Circle that has a mr. juice man juicer
eats organically grown broccoli their
average cholesterol ranges from 250 to
350 and yet they're legendary for not
getting cardiovascular disease until
they come down to the lower 48 and eat
like us then when they get the
cardiovascular disease they go back home
to die up above the Arctic Circle they
start eating whale blubber again it goes
away well learning all that I felt very
confident in telling my patients look
we're gonna do something different my
goal as a physician is to have my
patients died an average age of 100 I
don't want my patients down in 75.5 I
want to give them another 25 years I
want the average lifespan for my
patients to be 100 and we're gonna do
something different if you want to do
everything that all the other doctors
and patients are doing I want you to go
to them because I don't want you to
lower my average right we're gonna do
something different it's just real
simple my favourite disease is arthritis
I love arthritis the reason why I love
arthritis is it's easy to fix and when
you can fix something is horrible and as
debilitating as painful is expensive and
as miserable as arthritis you get kind
of excited about this concept of
preventing and curing diseases with
nutrition and so I tell people about
this arthritis thing all the time so
let's have a quick look at arthritis
number one 75 to 80% of all Americans
over the age of 50 get arthritis to one
degree or one type or another and
according to the CDC the Center for
Disease Control 35 to 50 million baby
boomers are going to get arthritis in
the next seven to ten years and there's
not a single medical treatment designed
to prevent or fix it
aspirin certainly doesn't fix arthritis
caused the gastric bleeding and death
talen all doesn't fix arthritis causes
50,000 cases of kidney failure each year
5,000 which was so severe you need a
kidney transplant then there is
ibuprofen advil and Aleve these things
don't fix arthritis and they cause liver
disease and 2 to 5 percent of the users
including liver cirrhosis even if you
don't drink
and then there's methotrexate and gold
shots these things don't fix arthritis
they subdue your bone marrow so you
can't make normal platelets and white
blood cells and then you have the
granddaddy's of all the medical
treatments for arthritis prednisone and
cortisone they don't fix arthritis they
subdue your immune system which leaves
you open to disease
is far far more horrible than arthritis
and prednisone and cortisone accelerate
the loss of minerals from your bones
something you don't want when you have
osteoporosis and arthritis now when
these prescription medications and
over-the-counter medications don't work
anymore to relieve pain and inflammation
the only thing left for you medically is
joint replacement surgery and I never
like to send my patients in for the
joint replacement surgery because they
never work out well in fact many times
you're worse off after the surgery than
you were before the surgery the
advantage my patients have always had is
that I'm a veterinarian as well as a
physician and so I always used to tell
my patients look we have all these
nutritional formulas designed to prevent
and cure diseases and animals including
arthritis and so I tried adapting
nutritional arthritis form was designed
to prevent cure arthritis and pigeons
and turkeys dogs cats sheeps pigs horses
cows lions tigers and bears to human use
it was no surprise to me it works just
as well in humans as a dozen animals
because it was designed to prevent and
cure arthritis and pigs and I literally
seen tens of thousands of people who
have had a regrowth of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue bone
foundation bone matrix doesn't matter if
they're 20 30 40 50 60 70 80 90
I've seen people 97 years old regrow
cartilage and bone even if they had bone
to bone arthritis if there's blood
supply to that joint and that bone they
will regrow bone and cartilage
well of course Harvard Medical School
goes berserk when you say stuff like
that
well like you can't say those things the
only thing left for people when they get
bone to bone arthritis is joint
replacement surgery and I'd agree with
him if the only raw materials are using
his talent all in aspirin and prednisone
and cortisone we have learned over 50
years that you can't regrow cartilage
and bone using those things one of the
basic things of course at the Harvard
Medical School jumped onto and he said
this is so ridiculous that this couldn't
work and so they took 29 patients
arthritis patients who had failed to
respond in any way to heroic medical
treatment for arthritis over 15 to 20
years they took them off all their
medication wasn't working for him anyway
lined him up for joint replacement
surgery they said look for 90 days
before we do the surgery they gave him a
heaping tablespoonful of ground-up
chicken cartilage there are seeds every
morning for 90 days they were sort of
chuckling in their beer saying nothing's
going to happen well here's what
happened in 10 days these people these
29 people had complete relief of pain
inflammation some they hadn't had in 15
to 20 years in 30 days they can now open
up a new pickle jar they've never been
over
without paying to the fingers wrists
elbows and shoulders in 90 days 28 of
the 29 were clinically cured now this is
from Harvard Medical School in the
Boston VA that meant that they had
complete return to the range of motion
all the pain inflammation was gone and
their fingers and toes and hips and
knees and her neck and certainly many of
them still had knots on their fingers
because there's only 90 days and you
think they'd call me up these professors
you know medicine from Harvard Medical
School and from the Boston VA and say
look Wallach we have to apologize to you
we've been bad-mouthing you for 20 years
and why don't you come up to Boston
let's talk about the whole thing
here's what they said quote after three
months it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote chicken cartilage had
become a drug in 90 days
now why would that happen well because
you can't patent chicken cartilage and
they convinced that the US Patent Office
that they were using a drug to do this
study and they actually got a use patent
on chicken cartilage and you too for
thirty five hundred bucks a month can
get Harvard Medical School's chicken
college and a capsule for arthritis of
course
cartilage has chondroitin sulfate in it
glucosamine sulfate collagen these are
all the basic raw materials to rebuild
cartilage and bone raise your hand if
you know what the red warning lines for
on the dashboard of a car truck back
before we had dials showing temperatures
and things they used to use the red
warning light right was called the idiot
light and when that red warning light
came on
it meant that your engine was heating up
you didn't have enough coolant or oil or
maybe a broken fan belt or splitter
radiator hose and a reasonable person
would would pull the vehicle car truck
over the side of the road and deal with
the problems they didn't burn the engine
up even the inner Mercedes would burn up
if you didn't have enough coolant and
oil and a fan belt and radiator hose
then of course the village idiot that's
what they called the village idiot light
or the idiot light they'd be driving
along they see that red warning light
come on
is that I don't have time to deal with
this so they whip out their flowers that
cut the wire of the red warning light
they keep on driving even a Mercedes
will burn them if it doesn't have oil
coolant a fan belt andrade or hose right
and so you really have to be the village
idiot to do that nobody in the right
mind would do that to their vehicle how
many of you know what pain is far raise
your hand if you know what pain is far
that's pretty good most of you know that
pain is the red warning light for your
body when you get pain in your foot your
ankle or your leg your knee your hip
your back your shoulders elbows wrists
and fingers your body saying don't use
those joints don't use those bones don't
use those muscles until you fix them
it's absolutely criminal absolutely
criminal for a doctor to write you a
prescription for a pain reliever an
anti-inflammatory or muscle relaxant or
any of those combinations without
rebuilding the bones and the joints and
the cartilages at the same time if they
just give you a pain reliever just give
you an anti-inflammatory and are a
muscle relaxant without rebuilding the
joints and the bones at the same time
all they're doing is cutting the wires
red warning light you're gonna wear
those bones and joints and cartilage out
faster and faster and faster it's
actually a negative to be taking
painkillers and anti-inflammatories
without rebuilding the joints and the
bones at the same time the reason why I
say no carbonated drinks and have been
doing that since 1964 is because
carbonated drinks action will neutralize
your stomach acid and you cannot a fish
absorbed minerals digest protein are
absorbed bottom and b12 without stomach
acid you have to have stomach acid like
battery acid doctors have the criminal
belief that you don't need stomach acid
and they give you all these drugs to get
rid of your stomach acid antacids and
they gave you drugs that stopped
producing stomach acid right they don't
want you to have stomach acid absolutely
criminal you can't digest food and
absorb food without stomach cancer I
know most of you knew that carbonated
drinks neutralized stomach acid if you
remember back 25 50 75 years ago when
somebody would answer doctors say look I
just needed I overate
I overate a Thanksgiving dinner and I
have heartburn and indigestion what do I
do that was before they had zantac they
say well take some 7up bring some ginger
ale drink some club soda take take some
sparkling water because the carbonation
will neutralize your stomach acid and
give you some relief and it would now if
you do that three times a year drink a
carbonated drink three times a year for
Thanksgiving and Christmas and Easter
because you overeat during those holiday
that's okay you're gonna survive when
you're drinking 2 3 4 5 6 8 10
carbonated drinks a day you're not going
to survive because over the long haul
you will not be able to absorb the
nutrients you're going to get some
horrible combination of terrible
diseases this came out June of 2000 this
is a Harvard study on 416 junior high
school girls in 9th and 10th grade and
what they found out was that those
junior high school girls who drank one
non Kohler carbonated drink every day
they increased their risk of fractures
and osteoporosis as a teenager by 300%
they found out that if they drank one
carbonated Cola drink a cola carbonated
drink every day
they increase the risk of fractures and
osteoporosis as a teenager by 500% now
do you think that this is more dangerous
for teenagers or adults there's much
more dangerous for animals because you
only have 25% bone matrix and you're
very very slow to recover where
teenagers have 40% bone matrix and they
can recover in a week's time we learned
in 1957 from a turkey study where they
took 250,000 turkeys and they put them
on a complete turkey pellet trying to
get them to finish for market within a
few days or a week or so of each other
and in the first 13 weeks fully half of
125,000 of them died farmers are out
there every
they picked him up every morning by the
bushel basket bolt took him to the state
diagnostic lab to see what they died
from when they opened him up every one
of them had died of a ruptured aortic
aneurysm and one of the clever
pathologist says that's got to be due to
a copper deficiency because copper is
required to manufacture the elastic
fibers of arteries and skin and other
tissues and the mechanism of an aneurysm
is identical to the mechanism of a
balloon on a weakened wall of a tire you
know when you hit a chuckhole with your
tire you break the cords the internal
pressure blows a balloon you overload
that tire with weight or heat it up on a
highway it blows out same way with an
aneurysm when you have a comprar
deficiency you get a breakdown in the
elastic fibers in that artery the
internal pressure even normal blood
pressure will blow a balloon in that
artery and a balloon in an artery is
called an aneurysm and of course if it's
in a strategic place like the brain cryo
artery the coronary arteries the large
arteries of AR to pulmonary artery renal
arteries they blow out you die suddenly
just like you've been shot well they got
excited about this they doubled the
amount of copper in these pellets the
next year they tried to raise 500,000
turkeys and they did not lose a single
one from a ruptured aneurysm they went
from a 50% loss to a 0% loss just by
adding a little bit of copper to those
pellets so they said well maybe the same
thing is true for humans in 1958 they
started looking at copper deficiency in
various species of animals and humans
and here's what they found out the very
first symptom of copper deficiency is
white gray and silver hair copper is
required as a cofactor to manufacture
hair pigment doesn't matter if it's
blonde Red brown or black hair and I see
a lot of copper deficiency in this room
I can almost tell you which people men
and women who colored their hair yet
pretty good at that being a physician
and you don't want to be like a medical
doctor and just treat the symptoms if
you're just coloring your hair you're
treating the symptoms you need to do the
basic thing take some colloidal copper
and if you don't what's going to happen
is you get a breakdown of the elastic
fibers in your skin and you start
getting crow's feet around the corners
of your eyes in your mouth parts of your
Anatomy begin to sag and you know you're
in trouble when your doctor tells you
look I've got a golf buddy down the hall
there's a plastic surgeon for $10,000
I'll make you look 20 years younger but
you don't need a facelift a boobie lift
a tummy tuck or a derriere lift all you
need is some copper and everything will
come back up just like you have a
hydraulic jack under it so just
right back up those elastic fibers
tighten right up people say Francine did
you get a facelift you look great you
looked like you're 20 years younger if
you don't take some action at that point
the next thing that happens is you get a
breakdown of the elastic fibers and
large veins of your legs and you get
varicose veins you don't take action at
that point you get a breakdown of the
elastic fibers and large veins of your
exhaust pipe and you get hemorrhoids so
if you have hemorrhoids varicose veins
things that sag wrinkles white gray or
silver here the eyes already have
aneurysms developing in you somewhere
and you don't want to of course died
suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm when
your body's been warning you for 10 20
30 years just remember people don't die
suddenly of an aneurysm it may be you
drop and die think about old Albert
Einstein he died of a ruptured aortic
aneurysm in 68 years of age what color
was his hair he was famous for wild
white hair wasn't he now you'd like to
think the people who win the Nobel Prize
in medicine but at least lived to be
75.5 but they live to be 58 just like
other doctors and of course that's
because they are trained and they
believe and they practice you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups doesn't matter if they win the
Nobel Prize or not this guy here dr.
George Kohler was the youngest person
ever to win the Nobel Prize in medicine
in history 37 years old wins a Nobel
Prize in medicine and he won the Nobel
Prize in medicine for studying
monoclonal antibodies which are
antibodies trained to attack cancer
cells if they ever get this really
working
it'll be great because they won't have
to use chemotherapy anymore which kills
more people and it saves 11 years after
winning the Nobel Prize in medicine dr.
George Kohler now 48 drops dead of a
cardiomyopathy a heart attack because he
believed you can get everything you need
from your for food routes didn't take
any selenium died of a carne mob with a
heart attack I have to tell you why
athletes our early warning system couch
potatoes by definition are people who go
to extraordinary efforts not to sweat
right they make every human effort not
to sweat they're changing the TV
channels honey bring in the popcorn I'm
changing the channels son bring me the
TV Guide I'm changing the channels by
contrast athletes have the attitude no
pain no gain and they're out there
sweating and working away power training
strength training running and they sweat
athletes no matter age they sweat more
in five years in couch potatoes doing 70
years and when you sweat you don't just
put out potassium and Gatorade you just
put out all sixty essential minerals
if you sweat out all of your selenium
and don't replace a by supplementation
or a higher risk of getting a
cardiomyopathy heart attack you sweat
out all of your copper and don't replace
by supplementation your high risk of
developing an aneurysm and dying or
suddenly of a ruptured aneurysm is what
out all of your chromium and vanadium
and don't replace by supplementation
higher risk of getting diabetes and if
you sweat out all of your calcium and
magnesium and boron and zinc and sulfur
and other minerals are required for
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue bone you're gonna get a joint and
bone injury what is the biggest single
cause of an athlete's career being ended
early joint and bone problems right and
that's because they sweat out all the
basic minerals that they need to
maintain those parts of their body they
don't supplement with them because
doctors tell them that they get
everything they need putting their four
food groups well what are the early
warning systems for mineral deficiencies
we already told you about white gray or
silver here for a comprar deficiency
their response are age spots in the back
of your hand side of your face or neck
these things are caused by a selenium
deficiency and you know again about
selenium deficiency then of course you
have toe cramps leg cramps so you can
have hypertension these things are all
caused by a deficiency of calcium and if
you're an athlete at age 25 or 15 and
you get a leg cramp is a calcium
deficiency your body's telling you if
you don't stop drinking those Pepsi's
and start supplementing with some
calcium by the time you're 40 50 60
years old you're gonna have arthritis
and osteoporosis but most people say oh
I got to get this high-priced trainer I
need somebody who can give me the
massage therapy because I have a cramp
and they don't go and take their
supplements 85% of the total mineral in
your body is a calcium
there's 147 different diseases you can
get from a calcium deficiency we're just
gonna quickly go over the top ten when
it comes to number of people affected
and the amount of money involved let's
look at osteoporosis the number 10
killer of adults the United States
remember 75 percent of those over age 65
who fracture a hip or major leg bone
don't live 90 days also is the most
horrible disease when it comes to human
misery and dollars expended osteoporosis
think of the special vans and the lift
gates and the ramps and the elevators
the special plumbing in homes and in
public buildings special parking places
wheelchairs and walkers and canes think
of the beds and the chairs there are
little electric motors to lift you up
when you can't stand up by yourself
physical therapists joint replacement
surgeries pharmaceuticals doctors
we're talking billions and billions of
dollars for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency disease
now as horrible as a disease is
osteoporosis is in human beings we don't
have osteoporosis and animals because we
don't have BlueCross BlueShield major
medical hospitalization Medicare and
Medicaid to pay for nonsensical surgical
treatments from mineral deficiency
we've learned that by putting animals
who are weaned off their mother's milk
on calcium as soon as they're weaned
they won't get arthritis osteoporosis
it's amazing how that works
receding gums Denis and dental hygienist
will tell you to floss and brush after
every meal if you believe that works I
have some oceanfront property in Montana
to sell yeah
if you have receding gums periodontal
Ida's pyuria loose teeth bridges and
plates you actually have osteoporosis of
the facial bones and the jaw bones we
don't get receding gums and animals even
though they don't floss or brush that's
because we've taken care of the
osteoporosis problem and animals
arthritis 85% of all arthritis is called
wear and tear arthritis osteoarthritis
degenerative arthritis ankylosing
spondylitis these things are nothing
more than osteoporosis of the joint ends
of the bones hypertension high blood
pressure as you've learned has nothing
to do with salt or salt restriction 85%
of hypertension not related to kidney
disease
which is most of them not related to
kidney disease is in fact a calcium
deficiency insomnia is not a deficiency
of sleeping pills
Halcyon or barbiturates it's a
deficiency of calcium kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
again the medical profession has a
malignant dumb belief that these things
are due to too much calcium in your diet
to give up calcium when in fact you only
get kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs
and calcium deposits when you have
raging osteoporosis you actually need
more calcium more magnesium not less
cramps and twitches raise your hand how
many very had a toe cramp foot cramp leg
cramp in your life sure that's the first
symptom of a calcium deficiency that
most people recognize so if you ever had
that sometime your life you've had a
calcium deficiency then you have PMS the
University of California at San Diego
came out and said that 85% of the
emotional and physical stuff of PMS can
be relieved eliminated and cured they
use the Cure word by taking three times
the RDA of calcium low back pain has
nothing to do with disc problems I know
you've heard of people maybe even
yourself have had a disc
for back pain and after the surgery he
still had the pain maybe even worse
because back pain is not caused by disk
problems if you have a disc problem you
can have numbness and tingling maybe
even paralysis it was very severe
but disc problems do not cause pain we
learned in 1957 and animals that we
could prevent and cure adult onset
diabetes with - trace minerals chromium
and vanadium 1985 the medical school at
the University of Vancouver British
Columbia in Canada came out and said the
trace mineral vanadium alone can replace
insulin and add all onset diabetics
sighs dog food has 40 minerals in it
always has chromium vanadium lithium and
selenium ralston purina laboratory rat
pellets has 28 minerals always contains
chromium vanadium lithium and selenium
I'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new 100 our bill if you can find me a
human infant formula off the shelf of a
grocery store that has more than 12
minerals in it none of them can contain
chromium vanadium or lithium only one
pro so while to actually pros Dhabi and
Enfamil I believe has 12 because they
put in the selenium the rest of them
don't they have 11 10 9 or 8 minerals
our dogs get 40 minerals our rats get 28
and our kids get 12 or less you don't
have to be a research scientist to
realize why our kids are now getting all
these horrible diseases that used to
occur in people in their 60s 70s and 80s
all these diseases that doctors are
wondering how is this genetic these kids
shouldn't have this tiller 60 well
that's because they couldn't get it out
of their little can of stuff if it's not
in the can they don't get it again we
need nutrients 16 minerals 16 vitamins
12 essential amino acids 3 essential
fatty acids and fortunately over the
thousands of years and human beings have
been around we haven't had to think much
about this because our food plants our
grains vegetables fruits and nuts take
carbon dioxide out of the air and
manufacture long carbon chains many of
which are vitamins amino acids and fatty
acids and this is where this medical
caca came from that you can get
everything you need from your four food
groups because they say well plants
grains fruit specials and us can
manufacture vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids but we've tried this
experiment for 200 years Americans have
eaten better than anybody else in the
world we've had the best quality food in
the world over anybody else and yet we
only live to be seventy five point five
we don't set any health and longevity
records so if you want to live to be
over 100
can't get it from eating your four food
groups you can live to be seventy five
point five you may live ten years older
ten years younger but on the average
seventy five point five so you want to
live to be over 100 you do have to
supplement with vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids there's three types of
minerals you have to concern yourself
with first of all there's metallic
minerals these are things like oyster
shell eggshell limestone coral calcium
sea bed minerals Clay's various types
tums is a popular one with doctors
lactate gluconate sit traits oxides
sulfates carbonates these are nothing
but ground of rocks we're not designed
to eat ground a Bronx nobody can show
you where humans or animals are designed
to eat ground up rocks
we're designed to get our minerals by
eating plants grains vegetables fruits
and nuts and as a result plant derived
minerals are observable more absorbable
than chelated more absorbable than the
elemental or metallic minerals plant
derive minerals are liquid they're very
small particle size there's seven
thousand times smaller than a red blood
cell this is the way they're stored in
your cells and are moved around in plant
vascular systems and human vascular
systems in the liquid plant derived farm
they're negatively charged I don't know
all of the physics and the chemistry is
one of the basic features of a colloidal
mineral it's negatively charged these
three factors together give you absorb
ability the way it's supposed to be is
our food plants our grains vegetables
fruits and nuts take the elemental or
metallic minerals out of the soil
convert them to minerals for their own
use for their own metabolism and
biochemistry and then animals and people
eat these plants that are enriched with
minerals that's how we're designed to
get our minerals unfortunately we have
several problems here for a hundred
years
we've used a simple fertilizer known as
NPK we put in three nutrients into the
soil when we need sixty minerals we put
those three nutrients in the soil for
maximum yields per ton and bushel per
acre then of course we have to
understand the plants cannot manufacture
minerals if they're not in the soil
they're not in the plants plants only
have minerals in them if they're in the
soil plants cannot manufacture minerals
over ninety years at least we've been
deficient in our soils in America and as
a result our food is deficient and as a
result the crops the grains fruits
vegetables and nuts that are grown there
are merely deficient and as a result the
animals and people who eat these mineral
deficient crops get mineral deficiency
diseases and the
way to prevent and cure them as with
mineral supplements
yes I'm a construction worker and I hurt
my back he said that my cartilage damage
is permanent is there anything that can
be done first of all how old are you I'm
28 years old and what do you normally
take for fluid replacement we were
working out in construction what do you
drink during the day water gatorade you
don't drink any soft drinks yes I do
okay cause normally construction workers
drink a couple of litres of Pepsi a day
right yeah I can probably put down a
liter pan and did you take any vitamins
or minerals that we were working a
construction just recently started when
you're in construction prior to the neck
problems yeah a lot of construction
workers will tell me well doc if it aint
and the Pepsi I don't get it right and
so you're a perfect candidate for the
Pig arthritis formula plus the EFA you
need all 90 essential nutrients and give
up the bad things give up the soft
drinks in the iced tea and the
lemonade's and and go up the fried foods
and the margins and I can just tell you
with your age you can honestly expect to
see some really recognizable results in
a very very short time 60 90 days and it
doesn't matter what the doctor said if
you do the right things get rid of the
bad stuff take all 90 essential
nutrients making sure you get that
collagen and the glucosamine sulfate in
the chondroitin sulfate you will repair
your vertebrae you will repair the
cartilage and you will repair the discs
dr. Wallach just seems like every week I
pick up a newspaper and I see about our
young athletes having problems with
their bodies falling apart what can we
give our athletes and our children so
that they can be healthy and have long
lives that we want as well that's a
great question because most people
believe that exercise is good for you
and it was always a great question you
know it is exercise good for you is it
necessary for health and longevity
and when you inspect this question you
have to look at professional athletes
who spend most of their teenage years
and going through University and the
semi pros and opposed training and
practicing and doing their events and
and if exercise was the factor in living
a long healthy life athlete should live
longer than couch potatoes but when you
look at this critically couch potatoes
in America lived to be seventy five
point five
and the average athlete depending on the
sport and their level of competence
lived to be 62 to 68 far short of what a
couch potato lives to be and of course
athletes suffer from a great many joint
diseases and bone injuries and tendons
and ligaments back neck shoulders ankles
knees and hips and they have to suffer
through an enormous amount of surgeries
to deal with this and athletes develop
some 800 different diseases what is it
why is it that athletes don't fare as
well as the couch potato was simply
because athletes sweat more in five
years than couch potatoes do in 75 years
and when you sweat you're not just
sweating out Gatorade you're sweating
out all 60 essential minerals and
they're called essential minerals
because if they're missing for any
length of time you get some horrible
degenerative disease many of which are
life-threatening so you don't have to be
a rocket scientist to figure out who's
more likely to be debilitated or even
die of these these life-threatening
diseases an athlete who sweats out
quarts of sweat during an event or
training or practice or a couch potato
who's laying on a couch and
air-conditioned dents switching the
channel is yelling honey bring in the
popcorn changing the channels and this
is very serious because the Center for
Disease Control says that as many as a
hundred thousand young athletes under
the age of 30 100 thousand each year die
suddenly during an event our training or
exercise or immediately after an event
from cardiomyopathy heart disease and
ruptured aneurysm and we know that
cardiomyopathy heart disease is due to a
selenium deficiency and ruptured
aneurysms is due to a copper deficiency
so you can begin to put two and two
together why does a ten-year-old died of
a ruptured aneurysm well you sweat out
all of this copper and you can't get
copper from curly french fries and Pepsi
just doesn't work dr. Wallach what about
arthritis
well arthritis is my favorite disease
because it's easy to fix it's one of the
great myths that the medical profession
perpetuates is that you can't build bone
mass after the age of 50 60 70 years of
age you can only slow down the loss and
the reason why they say that is because
they try to rebuild bone mass using
plain calcium whether it's tums or
calcium citrate or carbonate or
gluconate ER or lactate and your body
will not retain much or any of the
counts
a supplement within your bones without
first building new bone matrix you have
to have new bone matrix this is this
there's a rubbery collagen material that
looks like ten and her skin and it makes
up 25 to 40 percent of our bone weight
forty percent when you're a child and
twenty-five percent when you're an adult
and so it's absolutely essential if you
want to deal with the wear and tear
arthritis osteoarthritis degenerative
arthritis ankylosing spondylitis
effectively you have to take on 90
essential nutrients and the best way to
do that is with dr. Wallach spigots
riders formula remember I'm a
veterinarian as well as the physician
and we learned a long time ago maybe a
hundred years ago in veterinary medicine
that we could actually prevent and
reverse maybe even use the Cure word and
animals arthritis simply by giving the
animal the raw material to develop
properly and to maintain repair the
joints and so using this information
that we developed in animals if you use
the same concept for human beings
I have literally seen tens of thousands
of people over the years who had bone to
bone arthritis they had osteoarthritis
they have degenerative arthritis
ankylosing spondylitis which are
basically a joint form of osteoporosis
osteoporosis the joint ends of the bones
and they've tried all kinds of
medication and of course if you take
medication if you take a painkiller if
you take an anti-inflammatory for
arthritis essentially all you're doing
is cutting the wire the red warning
light pain in a joint says don't use me
until you fix me and by taking a
painkiller by taking a anti-inflammatory
which will reduce pain you're allowing
that joint to be used even though it
would have been painful without the drug
and so you're wearing that joint out
faster and faster and faster and to me
it's criminally negligent for someone to
be prescribed a painkiller or an
anti-inflammatory for joint disease
without repairing the joint at the same
time and this is where the P arthritis
formula really shines and works just
like a charm in human beings so does the
same applies for bone spurs absolutely
bone spurs are a manifestation of
osteoporosis a person will get bone
spurs and calcium deposits when you have
osteoporosis just the opposite of what a
doctor will tell you and you need more
calcium
or magnesium you need the bone matrix
you need the college and the glucosamine
sulfate the chondroitin sulfate and
those bone spurs and the calcium
deposits will actually Ryoga tech chure
back down to a normal bone takes a
little while takes four to six months to
pull that off but you can do it on a
regular basis absolutely cancer seems to
be striking everywhere in our population
these days what do we have that we can
help people that are facing the
challenge of cancer that's a great
question back at the turn of the century
1895 1900 one out of ten Americans
developed cancer right now it's three
out of five and by the year 2050 is
projected two out of three people are
going to develop cancer in America the
onset of cancer appears to be directly
related to the amount of carcinogens
these are toxic waste either from
agriculture or from the industrial
wastes that we find in our air nor food
nor water in the dust around us and the
lack of the ability to to vent against
these these carcinogens in the most
common defense mechanism we have that
the one that we have access to in a very
economical way are the antioxidants like
selenium like the grapeseed extract like
the green tea you're looking at vitamin
E vitamin C beta carotene and avoiding
fried foods and margins and and things
we have control of eating as much
organically grown food as possible
and according to the medical school at
the University of Arizona this came out
in JAMA the Journal American Medical
Association December 25th 1996 I mean
we're talking about a great Christmas
gift to the American people they did a
wonderful study ten years it was a
double-blind study 1,300 people they
gave the study group 250 micrograms
which is one quarter of one milligram
we're talking an itsy-bitsy amount of
saline they just used selenium alone
didn't change anything else and by
giving these people 250 micrograms 1/4
of a milligram of the trace mineral
selenium they were able to reduce the
risk of esophageal cancer by 71%
prostate cancer by 16 9 percent greater
than two thirds
colon and rectal cancer by 64% almost
two-thirds lung cancer was reduced by 48
percent with you smoked or not and in a
parallel study from the University of
California San Diego
250 micrograms one quarter of one
milligram of selenium the trace mineral
selenium reduced the risk of breast
cancer by 50 to 80 percent and the same
study showed that if you already have
cancer if you take 250 micrograms of
SLAM every day you will in fact double
the natural history life expectancy of a
particular type of cancer for instance
lung cancer the natural history is about
a year brain cancer is less than a year
uterine ovarian colon breast cancer is 2
to 5 years prostate cancer is 5 to 8
years well just by taking 250 micrograms
of the trace mineral flamer every day
1/4 of one milligram according to the
University of Arizona's Medical School
you can double that life expectancy just
by doing that one thing and so if you
take the other antioxidants and give up
margins and fried foods and sugar and
caffeine and avoid as many of the
agricultural wastes and the toxic waste
from the industry that you can you will
be able to avoid an enormous amount of
cancer and if you already have cancer
doing other things such as taking the
antioxidants and getting on macrobiotic
diets and and so forth you can add many
healthful years to your life you can
certainly have a better quality of life
and many people will extend their lives
in a great way 10 20 30 40 years and
obviously there's no way you can look in
somebody's eyes and say you're the one
that's gonna live 50 years and so people
just have to do all the right things and
they're gonna get the best that can be
gotten from nutrition and the
supplements doctor were like I've been a
diabetic for about 30 years what can
what kind of mineral should I take to
help me so first of all are you an
annulled onset type 2 diabetic or a
juvenile onset type 1 diabetic juvenile
onset type 1 you are in insulin
dependent because the definition of a
juvenile onset type 1 diabetic is that
you do not make any insulin and so you
will never be able to wean off of
insulin you will always have to take
some insulin but there are - trace
minerals chromium and vanadium that will
make the insulin that you supplement
yourself with very efficient and most
people who are juvenile onset
type 1 diabetics are able to reduce the
amount of insulin they require to
stabilizer blusher by supplementing with
the chromium and vanadium normally a
person learns how to adjust their
insulin by taking their blood sugar once
or twice or 3 times a day and so you're
taught how to adjust your insulin intake
and just by following what you've been
taught as you supplement with his plant
derived colloidal and the chelated
chromium and vanadium you will be able
to get down to a new dosage of your
insulin and the value of taking the
whole pig arthritis formula is that
there's nothing worse than paying
attention to your blood sugar levels
your insulin intake and then dying of a
ruptured aneurysm because you didn't
sell a supplement of copper or
developing cancer because you didn't
supplement with selenium so it's very
important even though you're a diabetic
and that is your primary immediate
concern still over the long haul of
being a health conscious person just out
of necessity you're going to have to
supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and the odds are even though
your juvenile onset type 1 diabetic you
have every ounce to expectation of
living to be a hundred and symptom-free
if you do everything right
that's my questions on Alzheimer's why
is it more prevalent today that than it
was 15 20 years ago
Lashley alzheimers disease was a disease
that did not exist 40 years ago Allan
summers disease even by another name
could not be found in any medical
dictionary or textbook or taught in any
medical curriculum it only became an
entity in the medical literature in 1979
and today it's apparently the number
four killer of annals United States over
the age of 65 behind cardiovascular
disease cancer diabetes and incomes
alzheimers disease and it appears to me
with no doubt that is due to what I call
a physician cause disease because
doctors have have encouraged people in
fact demanded the people give up
saturated fat and cholesterol and move
towards a cholesterol restrictor or even
any cholesterol free diet to get their
blood cholesterol down below 200 and
they have created no less than 25 of
these cholesterol deficiency diseases
and to me Alzheimer's disease is one of
the big ones 75% of
brain weight is pure cholesterol it's
called myelin is this fatty stuff that
insulates each nerve fiber of the brain
and spinal cord and we can only make
about 10% of our daily need of
cholesterol the other 90% must come from
the diet and if a person is very very
good at giving up chicken skin and red
meat and dairy and eggs like a doctor
would have them do after about six or
eight or ten years are not going to be
able to keep up with the maintenance and
repair needs of the cholesterol for the
myelin and the brain and spinal cord and
so you can just expect that the person
is going to develop one or more of these
25 physician caused diseases including
acquired seizure disorders and
alzheimers disease now the best way to
avoid a Alzheimer's disease is need a
couple of eggs every morning for
breakfast not cooked in margarine or
fried you want to consume as much as 72
ounces of red meat every month I know
that sounds like a lot but it's just a
quarter-pounder day and you want to
supplement with all 90 essential
nutrients and when you get to the
vitamin E level you want to have at
least two thousand international units
of vitamin E and you'll want 500
micrograms of selenium and if you do
that even if you already have Alzheimers
disease you can expect to have a
significant amount of return of memory
great studies done by the University of
California San Diego in the Salk
Institute that says by taking 2,000
international units of vitamin E alone
even if you have advanced Alzheimer's
disease you can get a significant amount
of memory return i remodeled homes from
families you notice these little
children bouncing off of walls and what
they get for breakfast and a snack after
breakfast and then lunch again normally
has sugar in it is there any correlation
here with a DD absolutely back at the
turn-of-the-century
1895 to 1900 americans reading a half a
pound of sugar per person per year today
it's a hundred and fifty pounds of sugar
per person per year and if somebody out
there is eating 300 pounds because i
don't need any and i can tell you that
there's a direct correlation between the
increase in a DD ADHD depression manic
depression bipolar disease and the
increased consumption of sugar and if
you look at it there's five million
American children school-aged children
who are on
and Prozac and imipramine and other
antidepressants in school five million
drugged American kids in the preschool
and elementary school simply because
these kids are sensitive to sugar like
many people are sensitive to alcohol
there's good alcoholics who just kind of
go to sleep and they have a couple of
drinks there's the people who get
boisterous and sing loud Irish songs
when they take a couple of drinks and
there's some people who get violent and
very angry and become dangerous to
themselves and other people child abuse
spouse abuse they abuse their neighbor's
road rage is another way of looking at
this life-threatening situations people
actually will gain criminal behaviors
sometimes because alcohol acts like a
drug in them same way with sugar some
people when they take in sugar they have
low blood sugar and they just get drowsy
and fall asleep some people when they
take in sugar they get hyperactive and
boisterous and actually ATD ADHD and
then there's some people when they take
in sugar again we'll have road rage
they're very very aggressive and
reactive and can be dangerous to
themselves and their families and other
people in the community and to me it's
criminal for coca-cola machines and
candy machines in school and then wonder
why kids beat up on each other or shoot
each other well in addition to getting
all the sugar out of their life from
sugar frosted flakes and Pepsi's and
Reese's peanut butter cups and candy and
and Pop Tarts and syrup on their egos
they have to supplement with all 90
essential nutrients even little kids
from the moment they're born to develop
properly this includes their emotions
and repair and maintain themselves and
especially lithium chromium and vanadium
and there's an enormous amount of
research in human beings which show that
lithium deficiency results in a
hyperactivity a DD ADHD depression manic
depression and criminal behavior and so
they have do both and you can avoid all
this it's amazing just within days they
will be perfectly normal little kids my
next question is my husband and I are
thinking about starting a family and we
want to know the nutritional way to go
okay that's a great question okay long
example when when the children need to
start taking vitamins and minerals and
the answer is what
still an egg is when you want to start
them and so we've learned in the animal
industry and remember I'm a veterinarian
as well as the position we've learned in
the animal industry that we could
prevent as much as 98% of all birth
defects even ones that are thought to be
genetic in humans simply by giving the
females especially the females all known
essential nutrients for that species six
months prior to conception build up that
female animal's body and stores of these
essential nutrients so the embryo
implants in the uterine wall and
develops in an environment that has
optimal amounts guaranteed optimal
amounts of all the nutrients and you
will almost eliminate the possibility of
a congenital birth defect related to a
mineral or vitamin or amino acid or
essential fatty acid deficiency to give
you some idea of how successful this is
according to the University of
California San Francisco right now in
America one out of every 33 human babies
in America are born with some physical
or emotional or mental birth defect one
out of 33 in animals there's only one
out of 500,000 if they're fed these
commercial diets that have all the known
nutrients in them and so it is very very
easy to understand Willa please
supplement young women and men who are
in the childbearing years with these
nutrients that we'll be able to
eliminate totally eliminate cleft
palates cleft lip spina bifida eye
defects heart defects hernias various
types club feet no feet webbed fingers
and toes no fingers and toes muscular
dystrophy Down syndrome cerebral palsy
cystic fibrosis these are all
preventable with proper preconception
nutrition so the earlier that a couple
who wants to have normal healthy
children have a wonderful uncomplicated
pregnancy the earlier you can get on all
nine essential nutrients prior to
conception the better off everybody is
hello dr. Wallach the women in my family
are plagued with hay fever and asthma
and allergies and I don't want to join
those ranks is there a better way
absolutely let's start with asthma is
the easiest one to deal with asthma is
actually a deficiency of three nutrients
magnesium
manganese in the essential fatty acids
and by taking the pig Earthrise formula
twice a day you're going to get the
optimal amounts of the plant derived
colloidal and the chelated magnesium and
manganese and then by taking the minimum
daily requirement the nine grams of the
essential fatty acid and those three
nutrients together the magnesium
manganese the essential fatty acids will
allow you to produce what's called
prostaglandins prostaglandins are little
short-lived hormones that last in your
bloodstream in 30 seconds 60 seconds and
your body's continuously making them
kind of rapid-fire and when you don't
have those three nutrients you cannot
make the proper prostaglandins to keep
your bronchi and your trachea open and
that's when you develop asthma and it's
very common when people take all 90
essential nutrients including the
magnesium and manganese the essential
fatty acids within weeks or months the
tightness this constant tightness in
their chest is significantly reduced or
maybe even totally relieved the
frequency and the severity of their
asthma attacks is reduced
I would certainly still keep an inhaler
available intuition you know in case you
have some unexpected emergency kind of
like wearing your seat belt even though
you're on a smooth flight you you're not
going to anticipate sudden turbulence
you need to be prepared for emergencies
but you have every ounce expectation of
doing very well then
as far as inhalant allergies from dust
and pollens and seasonal ones from dust
and pounds and maybe constant ones from
danders and cats and dogs and chickens
and feathers and your pillows and that
kind of thing maybe even chemicals that
come out of rugs and Formica and new
cars like formaldehyde other chemicals
you want to get your immune system
working optimally so it can protect you
from these things because most people
are able to tolerate them and what
happens is when your immune system
doesn't have enough nutrition to
function optimally you become a victim
of these things assaulting you all the
time and so what you want to do is
number one take all 90 essential
nutrients or your immune system which
includes your liver and your spleen your
tonsils and your appendix your thymus
your white blood cells which include the
neutrophils
and the lymphocytes and the killer T
cells and so forth also you have
eosinophils and basophils you have
neutrophils all of these white blood
cells you have albumins and globulin x'
which are the the immune proteins you
have antibodies themselves
you have your digestive system your skin
your tears the mucus in your body all of
that requires 90 essential nutrients to
produce this immune system which is not
just your killer T cells it includes all
of these tissues and cells and organs of
your body also if you have these types
of problems you want to get some of
these hepa filters at your workplace in
your home when you sleep you can get the
ones that you plug in your car you want
to eat as much organically grown food as
possible you want to drink filtered
waters when you get as much chemicals
out of your diet as possible and the
reduce this pressure on your immune
system if you have food allergies you
want to have a five-day rotation diet
you want to take the enzyme which has
the pepsin and the betaine hydrochloride
which will help a person digest the
proteins down into single amino acid and
it's the proteins and the allergens such
as danders and foods and pollens and
dust that cause the the allergies and
even can initiate an attack of asthma
thank you you're very welcome is it
possible that you can take too much
that's a great question because people
are concerned about overdosing with
vitamins and minerals the general answer
is that if you look at the medical
profession according to the Center for
Disease Control Harvard Medical School
the US News and World Report Ralph
Nader's Sidney Wolfe RAND Corporation
and many many other well-respected
institutions they say that doctors kill
150,000 and 300,000 Americans each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence doctors injured 1.3
million Americans each year in hospitals
alone as a result of medical negligence
and doctors infect 2 million Americans
alone in hospitals as a result of
medical negligence for a total of three
and a half million casualties inflicted
on the American public each year in
hospitals just as a result of medical
negligence on the other side of this
picture there's not a single person
because overdose and
and minerals and trace minerals to the
point where they have to be hospitalized
or anything bad happen and so when you
compare the safety of vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals are compared
with standard medical procedures its
anonymously safe and that's why I'm so
excited about nutrition and the piglets
riders formalin the plant derived
colloidal minerals and that's the
direction I'd go dr. Wallach my 16 year
old daughter has been diagnosed with
fibromyalgia what can you do for her
well it's actually an easy one we
eliminated fibromyalgia and animals in
1957 and in sheep it was called stiff
lamb disease and also in sheep and
calves and foals baby horses and
chickens and turkeys and any any other
animal that was raised for meat the
disease is caused by a deficiency of
three nutrients the trace mineral
selenium vitamin E and the sulfur
bearing amino acid Matheny and there's
two things you have stitute to deal with
fibromyalgia number one eliminate the
free radicals and the trans fatty acids
that actually initiate damage to the
muscle and causes scarring of the muscle
tissue which is very painful even normal
muscle movement and you can understand
why they call it stiff lamb disease if
you have fibromyalgia first of all you
eliminate fried foods such as fried
potatoes that which are you know
teenagers live on fried potatoes right
so calves eliminate fried potatoes fried
chicken fish shrimp fried eggs
tempura stir-fry anything fried all
margarine salad dressings are the oils
and them have to be eliminated and then
again the pinger transform is perfect
because it has optimal amounts of the
trace mineral selenium and both the
plant derived coil in the chelated form
as optimal amounts of vitamin E and the
sulfur bearing amino acid Metheny and it
just works like a charm very quickly
within weeks or months so they feel and
they can recognize some benefit and many
people get significant benefit very
quickly dr. Bai like our baby formulas
enough for our babies when they're born
unfortunately not our formulas that we
give to dogs whether it's kind of like
size that dog food or the puppy our
kitten milk replacers for puppies and
kittens you're in raised by hand have 40
minerals in them including the mineral
lithium chromium vanadium and selenium
ralston purina laboratory rat fellows
contained 28 minerals including lithium
chromium vanadium and selenium there's
not a single human milk replacer on the
market on a off the shelf of a grocery
store it has more than 12 minerals
none of them contain lithium chromium
vanadium and only 2 pro soybean Enfamil
have selenium in them and it's tragic
that we give our dogs 40 minerals in our
ranch 28 and our kids 12 or less you can
begin to see why we spent 1.2 trillion
dollars for health care last year you
begin to see why we only live to be
seventy five point five half of our
genetic potential for longevity of 120
140 why we only ranked 17th and
longevity in 19th and health and us
somebody because we don't get the basic
raw materials to develop properly and
maintain or repair ourselves from the
very beginning I'll give you a tragic
example sudden infant death syndrome is
something everybody is familiar with we
eliminated sudden infant death syndrome
in animals back in the 1950s because
farmers can't afford to lose two or
three or five or ten percent of the baby
animals are raising too sudden infant
death syndrome when we learned there was
due to a deficiency of the trace
minerals lamb causing sudden death and
the most robust the help is of the baby
animals in the group or the herd of the
flock and we eliminated simply by giving
the pregnant mothers selenium and as
soon as the baby is born or hatched they
get selenium and if you look at the
human infant milk replacers on the
market only two of all of them puts Liam
in the final and so if I was going to
raise a child today
on these infant milk replacers these
infant milk formulas in a can or bottle
box I would pick the tube
both soybean Enfamil that have selenium
in them and to stack things in favor of
the child I would still give them from
the moment they're born a teaspoon for
20 pounds of body weight of the Peter
thrives from with twice a day obviously
you may not want to use the orange juice
in a newborn baby because they can
develop allergies to it but I would
still give them the plant derived plural
and the chelated minerals and vitamins
and amino acids and the tragic example
of this is 65% this is a known fact
sixty-five percent of all the babies
dying of sudden infant death syndrome in
America are being fed can milk replacers
two-thirds are the ones who die of
sudden infant death syndrome are being
fed these can infant formulas I
guarantee you they're being fed the ones
that don't have selenium in them and so
absolutely it's important to supplement
these babies from birth because you
can't get everything in each report food
groups certainly not all these canned
formulas